cet été je suis parti en italie même si
j'ai pas lu tout bronzé
[Musique]
youtube a testé les pédalos en pleine
mer
c'est parti
[Musique]
bon là j'ai changé de poste jeu
maintenant capitaine du navire bon si on
peut éventuellement faire un thriller
toutes parties s'efforcent à droite
[Musique]
le feu rouge un moment plutôt nul les
joies du camping autour de la tour de
pise
dans la ville de pise ya un grand jardin
avec 14000 mecs qui font exactement la
même photo et pour la photo la photo
voilà pour la croix
alors la face à la pression ce qui fait
une photo différente
tu vas te taper la grosse tour
[Musique]
chevalier d'or chevalet vers ping on
vient de seconde
lol chevalier noir je me dis rouge
ce chat lui même il pétards
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'impression de plus belle au type de
lelouch tél
dire quand jean paul ii il rentrera qui
quand on la demandait une photo
d'identité
une fois qu'il s'est un peu trompé sur
la taille il ment flipper
[Musique]
ma vie est nul je ne peux rien peur à
l'été que toi ouais super connu en
italie
tout le monde a vu la voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
adapté de la toile à matelas et sacs en
courant
et vous tenez quand même au média
internet ah oui
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas de rejoindre ma page
facebook norman fait des vidéos et de
manger 5 fruits et légumes frais par
jour permet